PRESENTER: Hi.
Good morning.
My name is Jason, and
I'm here to introduce
our wonderful speakers
today-- the authors of "State
of Play" and "Minecraft:
Second Edition."
Welcome.
Thank you.
DANIEL GOLDBERG:
Thank you very much.
PRESENTER: Cheers.
It's all yours.
DANIEL GOLDBERG: So my
name is Daniel Goldberg.
This, again, is my
co-writer, Linus Larson.
Thanks again for coming
down to listen to us.
We're authors and
we're journalists,
and we're based in
Stockholm in Sweden, where
we write about technology
and, I would say,
the intersection between
technology and society
and the economy in a variety
of different ways for a variety
of different publications.
And we also write books.
A few years back, we
released our first book
in English, which is
called "Minecraft:
the Unlikely Tale of
Markus 'Notch' Perrson
and the Game That
Changed Everything,"
which is, as the title
implies, a book about the game
"Minecraft" but also about the
guy who created "Minecraft"
and where the inspiration came
from, and why, I would say,
maybe it's a game that has
a lot of things to say.
The story of
"Minecraft" has a lot
of things to say
about the internet,
about digital technology, and
the world we live in today,
I suppose.
It's a great book, so please
read it if you haven't already.
But today, we're here
to primarily talk
about our new book, which is
called "The State of Play."
And "The State of
Play" is a collection
of essays about video games
and about video game culture--
more specifically, a
collection of essays
that all present
new and interesting,
and we would think, fairly
different, ways of talking
about video games and
approaching video games,
and maybe even
creating video games.
So that's what it looks like.
So we'd like to spend
about maybe 25 minutes
to talk about the major
themes and the major ideas
of the book.
And after that, I think we'll
have time for some questions.
And please do ask questions,
because it makes everything
a lot more interesting.
Yeah.
So actually, I'd like to
start off with a question,
actually, before we begin.
So just raise your hand.
Who here has read at least
one book in the past month?
OK.
So about half of you, which
is pretty good, actually.
So who here has played a video
game, at least one video game
in the past month?
Almost everyone.
So more of you have played
a game in the past month
than have read a book
in the past month.
That's good.
So going back to the
book, then, those of you
who read the book-- would
you say you learned something
from reading that book?
Or perhaps even better--
did that book change
your opinion on something?
Just raise your hand
if that's the case.
So almost everyone, I think.
Would you say the same
thing about the game?
Did the game teach you
anything or did the game change
your opinion on anything?
One, two three-- OK, so less
of you, which is the point,
I suppose.
That's interesting.
We'll come back to that.
But let's get started.
So video games-- video
games are everywhere today.
Everyone plays video
games-- people of all ages,
people from all over the world.
Games are on our phones,
they're on our computers,
they're on our games
consoles, they're on the web.
I think it's fair to say
that video games today
are one of the, if not
the most influential,
forms of cultural
expression in the time
we live in today, which is
sort of in this small room
proven by the fact
that more of you
have actually played
games in the past month
than have read books
in the past month.
And also, video games have
come an amazingly long way
in their very short history--
graphics, gameplay design,
gameplay features.
The ambition and the scope and
the budgets of big video games
are now at a point which
I think most people would
have had a difficult
time imagining only,
say, 20 or 25 years ago.
Just to give you an
example of this evolution,
then, there's two examples.
This first game that you can
see on the screen over there
at least-- "Super Mario
Brothers" from 1995,
released for the Nintendo
Entertainment System.
Who's played "Super
Mario Brothers?"
Almost everyone?
Everyone?
It's a fantastic
game, obviously.
And I would say one of
the all time classics,
and perhaps also the game that
has done the most in shaping
our perception of what a
video game should be like,
what a video game
should look like,
and what the basic
gameplay should feel like.
This is very much-- this
is what a video game is
for a lot of people today.
And jumping ahead.
This is a picture
from "Uncharted 3."
There's actually an "Uncharted
4" that came out, I think,
a couple of days ago or
a couple of weeks ago.
This was released
for the Playstation 3
by Naughty Dog studios
in-- I think it was 2012.
Who's played a game in
the "Uncharted" series?
A few of you, at least.
I absolutely adore
this game series.
It's a fantastic, really
big budget blockbuster,
very reminiscent of the
"Indiana Jones" films in scope.
It's a fantastic adventure.
And it's really a game series
that shows how far, I think,
this format has come in
terms of cinematic ambition
and storytelling ambition.
So brilliant series.
Yes, obviously, a lot
of things have changed,
but there are also
a lot of things
that haven't changed at all.
So going from "Super
Mario Brothers"
from 1995 to "Uncharted 3,"
which is just a few years old,
many things have changed, but
many things really are the same
as they always have been.
And I think one of the primary
things that I would bring up
is that both of these games are
primarily about the same thing.
So "Super Mario Brothers"
and "Uncharted 3"
are primarily games-- or I
would say, only games about fun.
They're created to
be entertaining.
And in fact, most
video games today
are still largely
produced as and meant
to be discussed as entertainment
products and nothing else,
really.
There is plenty of action.
There's plenty of adventures.
You're jumping around.
You're blowing a lot
of stuff up, which
is great fun, obviously.
But there's also an
almost complete detachment
from the world outside.
These games exist in a vacuum.
They exist in their own world.
And there's really
no attempt made
to engage with the
world they exist in,
the social and political
realities these games
are produced in.
So "Super Mario,"
obviously, it's
a game about an Italian
plumber in a fairy tale
rescuing a princess, battling
fire-breathing lizards
and jumping on
mushroom soldiers.
"Uncharted" is
about traveling some
of the most exotic locations
in the world in search
of treasures and
forbidden legends,
forgotten legends, shooting
hundreds of thousands
of bad guys on the way.
And of course, these games,
like all cultural artifacts,
they carry plenty of meaning.
There's a lot of meaning
and subtext here,
and there's lots of things that
can be analyzed and discussed.
But I think it's fair to
say that the producers
of these games-- of
both the "Super Mario"
series and the
"Uncharted" series--
are primarily concerned
with entertainment.
Their concern is
giving you something
that is fun to
play, which is kind
of the point, the whole thing.
There's nothing wrong with this.
This is a very--
for odd reasons,
this is a very sensitive
topic to talk about.
So I'd just like to
get this out of the way
before you start
throwing things at me.
These are fantastic games
from a design perspective.
And really, of course,
we should appreciate them
for what they are.
I know I do.
And again, I absolutely adore
both of these game series.
There's a lot of
interesting things
to be said about
technical progress.
There's a lot of things to
be said about games design
and how, maybe, the
"Super Mario" series,
which is a Japanese
series, have brought
with it lots of design
conventions to the West
and influenced how Western
game developers work today.
But again, just to
make that point again,
these are games that
are pure fantasy.
They don't really make an
effort to engage with the world
outside of their own.
They don't really make
an effort to carry
any sort of social
or political meaning
or make a point about the
social or political realities
of the world they exist in.
Recently, there is a
clear and very interesting
trend that we've noticed and
many other people have noticed
as well, where primarily
small and independent games
developers have
started using games
and started thinking
about games in a way that
is quite different from
the way it's been done
in the past-- more specifically,
thinking about how games can
be used to convey stories
and messages to try to make
a point about real life issues.
I thought I'd leave it to Linus
to talk a bit more about a few
of these examples.
LINUS LARSSON: Yeah.
So you may be familiar
with some of these games.
I'll take them one by one.
The first one is "Cart Life."
This is a game that was released
by game designer Richard
Hofmeier back in 2011.
This is a street
vendor simulator,
but it could just as well be
seen as a game about poverty
in contemporary America.
Here, you play as one of three
street vendor characters.
And they have different
backgrounds and features,
one being an immigrant
from Ukraine, for example.
But they all
struggle to make ends
meet with what little
amount of money
they get from selling
newspapers, bagels,
or coffee in an American city.
Gameplay in "Cart Life"
consists of the everyday task
of setting up your cart,
getting the necessary equipment,
and spending what little you
make on what is most important.
In "Cart Life," this
will force the player
to make some really
heart-wrenching decisions,
like should I use the money
to buy food for my cat,
or should I pay the rent
so that I'm not evicted,
or should I leave work early one
day to have the time to pick up
my daughter from school
even though it means I mean
I will earn even less that day?
As you can see here, the
graphics in this game
is fairly simple.
It's the kind of
classic pixel graphics
that you will see
in older games.
That may look primitive.
But after playing
this game for a while,
I have to say that the
interaction nature of the game
makes you take these
choices really serious.
The more time you invest in
the character, in the game,
the more invested you get in the
decisions that has to be made.
And after a while,
it doesn't really
matter how simple
the graphics are
or how they are
being sketched up.
You really feel the
struggle of the characters.
In interviews,
Richard Hofmeier has
talked about how he used the
simple graphics because that
will allow the player to
fill in the gaps themselves,
and also talked about
how he was inspired
to make this game from
his own experience
from bad and poorly paid jobs.
So moving on to the next game.
This is "Depression
Quest," released in 2013
by Zoe Quinn, who is also one of
the contributors to this book.
She created this
tale about depression
in the form of a text-based
choose your own adventure game.
Are you familiar with this
genre where you make decisions?
Some of you are
nodding, so I assume so.
Here, as a player, you
proceed by making decisions
in everyday
situations that would
be very challenging to people
suffering from depression.
And in "Depression Quest," as
you can see here, actually,
with the red choices, as
your condition worsens,
more and more choices that would
seem like the logical one--
perhaps the best decision
to make for yourself--
are being blocked
off one by one.
And again, something
quite unique to games
is happening here.
By blocking out options, I
think that's a really clever way
of using game mechanics to
convey the feeling of what
suffering from
depression can feel like,
where good options
may be obvious,
but feel out of
reach for the person
suffering from the condition.
Again, I think "Depression
Quest" had to be a game.
It's all text-based,
but I don't think
a straight read-through
of the material
would be very touching.
But when investing
yourself and your time,
something happens, and it
suddenly feels a lot more real.
Zoe was also very careful when
designing "Depression Quest"
not to make a
simplistic, happy ending.
So the game is a lot less
about solving puzzles
in the right way and
finishing the game,
and a lot more about
telling a story
and illustrating the features
of actual depression, not just
to create a conventional game.
Another very good example
is "Papers, Please."
This was also released back
in 2013 by a game designer
called Lucas Pope.
It emulates the work life
of an immigrant official
in a fictitious country
called Arstotzka.
And Lucas Pope has dubbed
this game a dystopian document
thriller.
When you're playing
this, on one level,
it is a fairly
simple puzzle game
where you use documents
and a rubber stamp
to decide who should be let in
or sent back into the country.
And when playing, it's
sort of an eerie feeling,
the kind of power
you get when you're
the one who decides
who gets sent back
or who is let into the country.
It's very dystopian,
and the setting
is completely
fictitious, but it's also
a powerful illustration of
the faceless bureaucracy
of modern day border control.
So we're both from
Europe, obviously,
and you're probably
aware of the situation
right now with
hundreds of thousands
of people from Syria and
other war-torn countries
knocking on our door.
And especially in
this situation,
I think a game like
"Papers, Please"
and the underlying
theme of the game
is topical to say the least.
In my mind, it's one
of the best examples
of how games can take on serious
issues, serious real life
issues, a lot more than what has
been conventional in the games
industry before.
One more example-- this
list can go on and on.
This one is called
"This War of Mine."
It was released by a Polish
game studio just last year.
It takes on the very
common theme of war,
but in a very,
very different way.
Here, you don't play as a
soldier, but as a civilian,
or actually a
group of civilians,
trying to survive in
a city under siege.
I think it's inspired by
Sarajevo in the 1990s.
You don't take on the
role of the sniper,
but rather, the civilians trying
to escape the sniper's shots.
And you don't go on missions to
try to track down and possibly
kill enemies, but you
sneak out in the night
to scavenge supplies
that you and your peers
will need to survive.
Also in this game,
you don't win per se.
The best outcome
that you can hope for
is to survive long enough for
a cease fire to be called,
thus ending the game.
Again, war is very
common in games.
And if most of the mainstream
blockbuster first person
shooters will be the
romanticized view of war,
a game like "This War of
Mine" is quite the opposite.
It's a very depressing
view of the war,
but it's also a very
beautifully designed game.
DANIEL GOLDBERG:
The big question,
obviously, is what's new here.
So all of these four games,
and many more among them,
are, in some sense, less, I
would say, about entertainment,
and possibly more
about something else.
All of these games
are fun, and they're
interesting to play, sure.
They're great gameplay
experiences in themselves.
But they also, again, attempt
to make a point about something.
There's a conscious effort to
say something about the world.
In that sense, they also become
very political creations,
because they have an opinion.
They engage with the current
political and social debate
in a way that hasn't
really been common,
I would say, in video
games design in the past.
And the difference
here-- I think
this is very important--
the difference here
is in the intention.
As Linus said, war is a very,
very common theme in games.
And again, of course a game
series like the Mario series,
for example, it carries with
it a lot of political meaning.
There's the obvious
feminist analysis
to be done, obviously, about
how Mario and Luigi are both men
and they always rescue
a princess who's
female from trouble, but you
never get the other way around.
So the men are
always very active,
the woman is always
very passive.
That's a very simple
thing, and there's
a lot of meaning in that.
But there's never-- I
would argue there's never
been a really conscious
effort on the part of the game
designers to address that.
In a sense, that means a game
like "Super Mario Brothers"
is, at least on one level, an
intensely apolitical creation,
whereas the examples we
have on the screen here
are very political.
Because as an example,
a game like "Cart Life"
attempts to make a very
clear and very deliberate
point about poverty in
contemporary society.
They all attempt to
illustrate and capture
real life issues,
problems, points of debate.
And no matter what the exact
views that are brought forward,
the intention in
itself means that these
are political
creations in a way that
hasn't been common in the
games industry in the past.
So there are, of course,
plenty of historical exceptions
to this.
This is one example-- a
classic 80s Atari arcade
game called "Missile Command."
I'm sure if anyone is familiar.
Most people would be,
I assume, familiar
with "Missile Command."
"Missile Command,"
it's a game where you
protect a series of cities
from nuclear bombs that
are falling from the sky.
And this game was
created with the stated
purpose of making people aware
of the horrors of nuclear war.
And this is also a game that
is described and analyzed
in more detail in one of the
essays in "The State of Play."
And it was actually designed and
originally titled Armageddon,
and it featured attacks on
actual cities in California.
So these cities that
you're protecting
would have names of actual
cities in California.
And for some reason--
possibly commercial reasons--
this was changed
before the game was
released into a more generic
aliens versus human scenario
where you're protecting the
Earth from an alien onslaught.
But I think the most
iconic feature of this game
was kept in the final release.
So when you fail a game
of "Missile Command,"
you don't get the
traditional game over screen.
You get a screen
that says "The End."
And this is possibly a
subtle hint that all out war
isn't a the game, isn't
over, but it could actually
spell the literal end,
possibly, for all of humankind.
So with this in
mind, I think you
could say that "Missile Command"
is an early example of game
designers taking their creations
seriously enough, maybe,
to realize that their
games carry meaning.
And it's up to the designer,
or the designer of the game
is free to decide what exactly
that meaning should be.
It doesn't have to be passive.
You can take an active role
in that as a games designer.
And again, "Missile Command"
and the various ways
that this game can be read, this
is subject of one of the essays
in "The State of
Play" by a historian
called William Knoblach.
And the essay is titled "Game
Over: a Cold War Kid Reflects
on Apocalyptic Video Games."
LINUS LARSSON: So another
thing that is changing here
is the way we talk about games.
Traditionally, games have
been discussed and reviewed,
especially, more than anything
else like pieces of technology.
Questions like, how
smooth are the animations,
and how advanced
are the graphics,
and how well balanced
the gameplay have
been central to the reviews.
Basically, games criticism
has had more in common
with the way we would
review a mobile phone,
or a car, or even a
refrigerator than criticism
of literature and music.
And again, there is absolutely
nothing wrong with that.
We keep repeating this because
people tend to get offended
if you talk about something
else than these aspects
as certain parts of
the gaming community.
Because this is a
perfectly viable way
of talking about games.
It's basically consumer advice.
And in fact, it
maybe doesn't even
make sense to talk about
a game like "Uncharted"
in any other way.
Some games are quite expensive.
Before you spend
$60, $70 on a game,
who wouldn't want some
straightforward consumer
advice?
I know I would like that.
So there is absolutely
nothing wrong with this.
But in the past few
years, a new generation
of critics and
academics have begun
discussing games
that place them more
in a social and political
context, looking
to understand what the games
say about the world around it.
There is currently
a lot of interest
in the feminist
criticism of games
brought forward by, for example,
Anita Sarkisyan, seen here,
and Catherine Cross, also seen
on the other side of the screen
there, two of the
most important writers
in covering this area today.
And there is a
growing debate on how
non-whites and
non-Western minorities are
being portrayed in video games.
[INAUDIBLE], who writes for
Gawker and Kotaku, who's
seen in the middle
here with his daughter,
is a key writer in this field.
He's also featured-- they
are all featured with essays
in "The State of Play."
So a couple of more examples of
how this discussion is going.
One of our contributors
is named Hussein Ibrahim.
He's a video game journalist
based in Beirut, Lebanon,
and the former editor
in chief of one
of the largest Arab gaming
websites in the world.
Hussein absolutely loved
first person shooters--
games like "Battlefield"
and the "Call of Duty"
series are his favorites.
The thing is, though, as
a player in these games,
he has noticed that a lot of the
people that you will be aiming
your gun at will be
people-- will be largely
Arab people in Arab countries.
So Hussein, when
playing, is basically
waging war on people like
himself in the very games
that he loves the most.
As he writes, as
an American, you
get to relate to
the hero defending
his country from terrorists
threatening your freedom.
As an Arab, you get to relate
to the guy who wants to blow up
your city, and that is all.
Now, this doesn't mean
that all that Hussein has
abandoned these games and wants
to encourage others to do so.
He's not advocating
a boycott at all.
Because he, like all our
contributors, love video games,
and keeps playing these
first person shooters.
But he does make some
fascinating points
of what it feels like to
have people who look like you
and talk like you always be
the bad guys in the game.
Another-- "The Joy
of Virtual Violence"
is the title of
one of the essays.
It's written as an exchange of
letters between game writers
Cara Ellison and Brendan Keogh.
And it explores the
dynamic that makes us enjoy
violent aspects of video games.
A lot of gamers are fed up
with the talk about violence
in games.
Some become very defensive when
the topic is even brought up.
And this is not very surprising,
because ever since video games
came about, there
has been attempts
to stigmatize the whole
form, or to censor
them, or to criminalize
sale of certain games
to minors, for
example, often done
with very little understanding
of what games are
and what makes us
want to play them.
But then again, this
essay, like all the ones
we feature in the
book, is rooted
in a love of video games-- this
specifically, love of violence,
sometimes very gory ones, where
a perfectly-executed headshot
can be the most
rewarding action.
But Cara and Brandon
are also decent people
who can be disgusted
by violence,
so their exchanges of
letters is an attempt
to reconcile these thoughts.
And obviously, this
discussion goes way
beyond the question of
whether video games should
be as violent as they are, and
is more interested in asking
why violence is such a
common theme in games,
and what it says about
games as a medium,
and possibly even
about ourselves.
DANIEL GOLDBERG: Because
everyone likes to shoot people
in games, right?
LINUS LARSSON: Certainly.
DANIEL GOLDBERG: I know I do.
There's nothing wrong with that.
So we think a good term for
describing the shift that we're
talking about is post-escapism.
To say that the way we talk
about games and the way games
are designed is moving into
a period of post-escapism.
In essence, this
means that we're now
beginning to move from a
time where games were only
talked about and only created
as products of entertainment,
and judged on
entertainment value
and possibly technical merit
alone, into a time where games
are and can be
discussed and examined
based on the way they relate
to the world they exist in.
And I think, in a way, this
is an important coming of age
for video games as a medium.
Again, if you make
the comparison
to literature or film, for
example, a genre like satire
has been around for
thousands of years
and does exactly the thing
we're talking about here.
But video games is a
fairly young medium, still,
and it's, in many ways, a
fairly immature art form.
But right now, we're
at one of these points
where games-- and again, the
way we talk about games--
is beginning to
take that next step
and change into something else,
or possibly something more.
So this means, one, we're
in a very exciting time
if you work with games.
Two, this is a
very exciting time
to be writing about
or discussing games.
And also, me and Linus
are convinced that these
are very positive developments.
Within the games industry,
as I'm sure many of you know,
there's a long tradition of not
being happy with the way games
and games culture is portrayed
in mainstream circles,
without the gaming community,
outside the gaming community--
the mainstream
media, for example.
But what is happening here
is that these developments
are opening doors, or
opening a lot of new doors,
for both video game
creators and critics who
have their background outside
of traditional gamer circles.
This is giving
them ways to relate
to the form that haven't
really been around in the past.
In a sense, by moving closer
to the world outside their own,
which is exactly what
games are doing right now,
games are becoming,
or have the potential
of becoming, much richer
experiences and much more
mature experiences
in the past while
also opening up for
completely new audiences.
And these audiences are
potentially much, much larger
than the ones that games
have had in the past.
So "The State of
Play" is our attempt
to capture what we consider
some of the essential voices
of this era.
The contributors are all game
developers, they're critics,
and they're academics who
all, but in very, very
different ways, make their
own small contribution
to this new way of creating
and thinking about games.
And if you decide to
read it, which we hope,
of course, all of
you do, we hope
it will help you
find interesting
and possibly new ways of
appreciating and understanding
this is lovely, wonderful
form of entertainment
that we are talking
about here as something
to be taken very
seriously and something
that is to be considered as
more than simply entertainment
for its own sake.
That's it.
Thank you all for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
LINUS LARSSON: We
are happy to answer
some questions if you have any.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious-- do you guys
have a perspective on
the social aspect that's
starting to develop
as we see more
and more of the kids,
especially teenagers,
spending the majority of
their social interaction time
now online, even counting time
they have to spend in school.
Being a parent of
one of those, I'm
curious to get your
perspective on it.
LINUS LARSSON: Right.
So you're talking specifically
about online games and the kind
of culture that evolves there?
AUDIENCE: In
particular, he spends
a lot of time doing team-based
activities in the first person
shooters.
DANIEL GOLDBERG: So this is
actually a good question.
This is something we talk about
quite a lot in our first book,
which is about "Minecraft"
and specifically
about some of the absolutely
extraordinary creations that
have come out of kids
basically self-organizing
around this game and
creating some really
stunning things using it.
I'm a parent also.
I have a two-year-old at home.
He's maybe not big enough
to play "Minecraft" yet,
but I'm getting to the
point where I'm asking
the same questions of myself.
I have a very inherently
positive view of these things.
I am not convinced
that-- or I don't really
understand why this in
itself-- why a screen in itself
and talking to someone over
the internet is a bad thing.
Why is that different
than talking
to someone in real life?
I'm not convinced that it is.
What I do know is that some
really fantastic things
can come out of this.
And possibly more specifically
related to "The State of Play,"
which is a book
where-- naturally,
a lot of the
discussion we bring up
centers around minorities
of various sorts
and how minority communities
are now beginning
to make themselves heard in the
gaming community in a way that
hasn't been in the past-- again,
very positive development,
I think.
And the internet, by opening
up to the rest of the world,
means that your chances
of finding someone
who shares your
views on things, who
shares your struggles in life,
are increased exponentially
compared to how it
was in the past.
So I agree, but I
think it's good.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
where you guys think
the language that we use to
talk about games will come from.
Because the medium is so young
that there's no codified way
to talk about it yet.
And I was wondering if you guys
have any thoughts about where
that will come from or what
that process might look like.
LINUS LARSSON: That's
a really good question.
Just looking at
the kind of essays
we got to include in the book,
they're extremely different.
They range from
the very academic
to the extremely personal.
Some of them are
written, as I mentioned,
as an exchange of letters.
There's so many ways
of talking about games,
and I think there probably will
be a multitude of it happening.
There must be something coming
from the fact that games
writing and games
journalism largely
grew-- emerged separate
mainstream media.
All mainstream media
struggled to cover games.
I work for a large daily myself,
and it's not entirely clear
how it should be covered
in circuits like that.
But I think the way you
can write about the games,
the language you can use
when talking about games,
has been affected by the
fact that it has grown
separate-- online, more
than anything else--
and separate from the way
we talk about literature,
for example, or film.
And while it could be
influenced by that,
it will keep some-- it will
be unique in some way as well.
DANIEL GOLDBERG: It is actually
a really good question.
And I think it sort
of connects to some
of the points we made
earlier about how,
one, as Linus is saying,
this discourse around games
has its roots in technology,
which means we've tended
to evaluate games based
on technological merit,
because that's the
language that is available.
And also, it connects to
how the new voices we're
trying to highlight
in "The State of Play"
are approaching games from
a different perspective
and using language that
is, perhaps, closer
to what traditional cultural
criticism, possibly,
has been about in the past.
And again, this is something
that is opening doors.
This means that a new generation
of critics and academics,
but also people who are
interested in games design,
are able to approach the
field and make something
interesting out of it without
the necessary background
or the background in technology
that has really been necessary
in the past.
It also comes down to
tools such as Twine.
Are you familiar with Twine?
Twine, for those of
you who don't know,
is a platform that
can be used to create
adventure games or
text-based games
without a programming
background.
And [INAUDIBLE] is one
of our contributors
in the book-- hasn't
got a coding background,
but creates really fascinating
experiences with a platform
like Twine, which
doesn't require
you to have a technical
background in order
to create games.
That's a really fascinating
thing to talk about, actually.
AUDIENCE: For me personally,
one of the things that's always
been very special about
video games and something
that's attracted me to it--
and I think that's also
a very powerful
aspect of games--
is the fact that when they're
trying to convey a message,
it's always a very
interactive experience.
So as opposed to reading
something or watching
something, actually stepping
into the shoes of someone who's
in this particular
situation does
a very good job of getting
these kinds of messages across.
But there has been a very large,
widespread new consumption
of games through things
like Let's Play on YouTube
and Twitch TV with streaming.
And I was wondering
what you guys thought
about the effects of this
more passive consumption
of video games as a medium.
DANIEL GOLDBERG: Another
great question, actually.
I agree.
And I think a game
like "Cart Life--"
if you haven't tried "Cart
Life," you should check it out.
It's a stunning experience
when you're-- as you say,
games make you identify with
the choices in a way that
isn't really possible in more
passive forms of entertainment.
And by forcing you to identify
with choices like do I
feed my cat or myself, it's
a heart-wrenching experience.
It's a very, very
strong experience
that isn't really possible
outside of games, I think.
I'm not sure.
Having said that, some
games are very well--
narratively-driven games
or story-driven games,
that isn't the whole picture.
And some games are very
suitable for-- a game
like "Cart Life" wouldn't
be as strong if you watch it
as a let's play, of course.
But watching someone
play-- I'm not sure.
I'm a big "Dark
Souls" fan myself,
and watching someone play the
"Dark Souls" series on YouTube,
it's a great
experience, because it's
sort of-- but it's
also different,
because it's more
about conveying
that feeling of playing
something with a friend
rather than playing it yourself.
But I think you're right in that
some gameplay experiences can't
really be conveyed in that
much more passive way,
or a lot of the
force is, perhaps,
lost in that transition.
I haven't got a good answer,
but it's a fascinating point.
LINUS LARSSON: And every
play through will be unique,
and every play through
will, to some extent,
tell a different story.
So reading about someone
and someone's experience
with a game, or watching them
play it in a certain way,
perhaps, this could tell a
different story every time.
One example-- there's
actually a comedian in Sweden
who made a point of
trying to play the latest
Sim City as a Swedish
Social Democrat
with the tax levels
we have, which isn't
even possible in the game.
They're capped way
below what we pay.
But if you max that out to try
to come as close as possible,
there will be absolute chaos.
There will be fires everywhere,
and the city you make
will just break down and
be completely destroyed,
and everyone will die.
Well, of course, that's
funny, but it also
obviously says something
where the makers of that game
came from.
DANIEL GOLDBERG: Awesome.
And again, thanks for
coming down to listen to us.
LINUS LARSSON: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]